[Music]
[Applause]
he Christopher madog Russo madog sports
radio yes he's still on the radio
SiriusXM you can see him on first take
as well and uh weekdays on MLB with some
high heat Mad Dog joins us now hi Chris
how are you good job with the Beatles I
didn't realize that story excellent on
your part excellent job enjoyed that why
today Beatles is there an anniversary
I'm not aware of what's going on the
Beatles just had that song that came out
uh yesterday where it's called Uh now
and then where it was something that
Paul or uh John wrote in the uh mid 70s
recorded it Yoko gave it to Paul Paul
all these years has been trying to come
up with something and he got together
with Ringo and George while he was still
alive and then they put out that song uh
that was yesterday so wow how about that
I didn't realize that good job on your
part boy how can you not the Ron Howard
documentary on the Beatles is tremendous
I'm sure you saw that it was great he
did a great job of it what did you think
of Peter Jackson's documentary on the
Beatles uh the one that was the 10p part
one that I got a little bored with it I
have to admit you know it was the same
thing day after day after day it was
unique the month of January and then you
see the concert there on the top of the
roof but I did get a little bored with
it I have to admit I got a little bored
with it but I mean you can tell how they
are and you know they come so naturally
they can sit there and wake up after not
sleeping they can just show up at a
thing half in a bag and they go out
there and they put songs together that's
how great they were they they weren't
half in the bag as much as the Rolling
Stones were oh I agree I completely
agree with that the Rolling Stones you
know I didn't realize their first
appearance on um Sullivan was in June in
1964 and I think the Beatles was that
previous Fe February so it's pretty
close yeah that the stones did The Ed
Sullivan Show three or four months Dan
after the Beatles basically woke up
America when they did I Want to Hold
Your Hand when was that I think February
of 1964 if I'm not mistaken I think he's
a Mad Dog Russo and uh you're still on
the radio I know that I I wasn't rooting
for the Diamondbacks until you said that
you would retire if the Diamondbacks got
to the World Series and I thought well I
don't want you to retire but I I do want
to see what you do
if the Diamondbacks get to the World
Series then you go to the World Series
you're in Arizona how did the fans treat
you when you got there you know funny I
was in the Centerfield bleachers uh
where the radio crew was and the high
heat thing was on the field the center
field bleachers for the radio so three
days you know I'm on 4 to 7 New York
time which is obviously about an hour
before game time that's you know 1 to
four and the game's at 50:3 so all the
fans are low below me on that little
ramp there in the Centerfield bleachers
I would say
80% totally into it pictures autographs
Mad Dog don't retire and then I would
say 20% nasty get out of here what do
you know about the baseball da retire
already so I would say about eight to
eight of 10 were good 20% were bad now
remember I took my I Northern Arizona my
kids at Northern Arizona who plays at
Con on Monday night by the way they're
opener and he's the third assistant so I
brought I got five tickets Monday night
to bring the coaches down so that was
sort of a little camouflage how they
gonna boo Me When I'm kissing my kid who
I haven't seen since dog that's number
one I tell you the guy who gets it is
that is T lll yeah he is well you know
that better than anybody he he
understands entertainment you know he
grew up on the set of all the family
because his father was the executive
producer of Hew which is a CBS show so
he grew up on a set of all a family so
he understands entertainment so he got
it the whole way through and sort of
Derek H their CEO some of the fans got a
little nasty that's part of the deal you
gotta now who thought I was gonna retire
anyway you didn't think that for find
out loud I thought it would have been an
unbelievable move unbelievable if you
walked away from your radio show which
is that's is that where you made the
guarantee yes okay so I thought now
granted you're walking away from a lot
of money
but that would have been ultimate in
because we do this a lot oh if that team
wins I'll walk to Philadelphia like that
local people like to do those things if
you said no this is my word you're a man
of
integrity did you even think of how did
it go over with your wife at home when
you said hun I did something stupid well
the one thing she didn't like was the
bikini walk down Fifth Avenue okay
Howard Stern wanted you to wear a bikini
that so that wasn't going to work is Mrs
Russo was not going to stand for that
and I can't blame her uh you know she's
used to the nonsense um I don't think
she heard it you know the first thing
that I was gonna give up Dan was going
to the Yukon game on Monday night did
you know that no that was the first
thing I said here's if they win the two
in Philly six and seven I won't go
because I'm not going to work Monday I
won't go to Yukon Northern Arizona and
then I said hold on now that that's too
painful I got to be there for his first
game so then I threw in the retire I
could care less so in essence I really
probably should have shown the guts
you're a th% correct I probably should
have done that so I have to take the
responsibility that I was too Carefree
about it and if you want to call me mad
fraud instead of Mad Dog I I have to
live with it I have to live with it the
funny thing is you probably don't know
this is I wasn't going to the World
Series
I was not going when I did that that was
Tuesday they win Tuesday night I go do
the first take on Wednesday morning did
you know that baseball call me at 11: a
Chris you have to go to the World Series
how could you not go now I couldn't go
to the first two games I said okay I'll
maneuver I got to get the radio out
there it's a lot of moving Parts you
know you got to make sure you have a set
for the first take I got to leave for
four days plus I did the Hall of Fame
last night in New York MC it so I had to
make sure I got back for that Mak a long
story short I said oh here's the deal
I'll go to the three games in Arizona
which is what I did he's mad dog Russo
and uh you can hear him in the afternoon
Serius XM also high heat and First Take
why is it we have a record book for wil
Chamberlain and then everybody else but
we don't have a record book just for
Babe Ruth than everybody else because
Wilt to me is Babe Ruth of of basketball
but it feels like you know cuz Wilt made
his debut and had like 41 points and 40
rebounds in in his like second or third
game in the NBA but that wilt's numbers
don't matter they're not like real why
is that uh you know I mean I it's a
little different I mean the 100 points
will stand up in history you know Dan
everybody's G remember everybody's going
to know who follows basketball Hershey
PA against the Knicks he scores 100
points now there was a lot of things
about that game I know you know this I
don't know if our audiences do that are
a little weird you know first off did
you know the Sixers the Warriors at the
time you know they fouled the Knicks in
the last 10 minutes of the game every
five seconds to stop the clock make the
Knicks shoot the free throws so they can
get wil the ball to get the 100 so
that's if that happened today people
would be screaming I know I would
wouldn't like that and the Knicks tried
to throw the ball all over the place and
play keep away so they wouldn't get
fouled and then they tried the foul whe
a lot to make sure he missed some free
throws because the whole idea was the
Knicks didn't want him to get to 100 and
Philly did the game was a blow out so
they fooled around at the game a lot and
that's how and he shot 28 of 32 from the
line that night which is pretty amazing
in Hershey Pennsylvania in front of
4,000 people but you're right the wilt
numbers uh what do you what number do
you think was more significant there for
a period of time wilts 100 or Aaron or
Ruth
I would say 714 because that was over a
career whereas W had that wonderful
night you know kobby had 81 Elgen Baylor
had a big night like guys have had big
nights babe 714 was you know that was
felt unapproachable I mean 100 does but
I've asked players and they feel like in
today's game shooting
threes that if somebody you know really
had one of those nights that you could
come close I mean Kobe had 81 but that
game was close with Toronto last game of
the year no it wasn't the last game of
the year no it wasn't the last game that
was the the game against uh
Dallas when he had a big game in his
last game Utah Utah yeah he had a big
game yeah but not he didn't have he but
he had 50 he didn't have 81 no uh yes I
mean I I I could see somebody going out
there making 23s you know something
crazy like that that 60 points like then
he you know makes some free throws and
everything else but the game has to be
close though I think to stay in the game
yeah the game does have to be close I
think the routes It's Tricky I think the
game has to be close um you know listen
Ruth he had so many unbelievable numbers
I think all the numbers get obscured by
the home runs I mean it's a 341 or 340
something lifetime hitter you know he
hit the 60 homers that Maris surpassed
uh you know his run scored his RBI his
walks his on base percent you can have a
catalog and pitching numbers I think the
two that stand out of the 60 and the 714
I mean even every even today people know
that Ruth who follow baseball now judge
broke it Maris broke it but they knew
that Ruth was the first to hit the
magical number of 60 uh you know wilt's
number the one number you know is the
100 I I think people know that he's
average 50 a game in that same season I
think people know that don't you think
most Bas basketball fans know that in '
62 he averaged 50.2 points a game I
don't know I don't know I I I
think I don't think anybody would be
surprised that he averaged 50 I like he
had you don't think they put two and two
together no I don't know if they go I
think they know 100 points in Will
Chamberlain and these numbers uh but he
would put up big numbers against Bill
Russell oh he sure did he and matter of
fact the game that you referred to there
when he had 41 and that was the first
game he had against Russell oh he played
great against Russell no qu he didn't
play great necessarily against him in
the playoff
but he played did you see the
Chamberlain documentary on Showtime yeah
they did a great job at that that was
excellent and the and they showed you
all sorts of highlights as a player they
brought up the fact that he had the torn
ACL and he came back early in 1960 he
heard it in 6869 he heard it the
following year he came back against the
Knicks and how about that tremendous
scene they showed you at Kansas when
they retired his number and he's crying
at Mid quarter at halftime of a Kansas
game which I had never seen before have
you seen that no I had not I had never
seen that was a CBS game I don't
remember that that was great the half
crying how this game he took to his
grave and then he died eight months
later when is it too soon to have I
don't like to say hot take but Victor W
bayama is going to be one of the great
players of all time I agree okay I I
know we're only a couple we're five
games in but I and I I don't deal with
hyp purbo or hot takes but I'm just
looking at this the only thing that will
prevent him from being one of the
alltime greats will be injury his body
body I I saw the first two games uh
parts of it when he was at home they
split and you could just tell he's all
over the place I I had PJ on about uh
last week and I said you know one thing
here PJ is I could see Pop not playing
on that many games and and and he said
you know Pap will play him plenty of
games not any2 but he play him 75 games
but they keep minutes down yeah so he
won you know he playing a lot of games
where to keep the minutes down but how
about the game last night he scores 38
points he makes big baskets all over the
place he shoots threes now he's frail
he's frail um you know but uh he's gonna
keep popping in the league for the next
10 years I mean that's all there is to
it I mean and pop loves it anyway which
is a great thing for the NBA and you
know they beat Phoenix twice that's two
good wins on the road against Phoenix he
scores 38 points what he have 13
rebounds last night you me 3810 but you
know here's pop who struggled the last
couple of years and he finds his next
Tim Duncan whereas bill bellich has
struggled good point and he's trying to
find a victor one bayama to keep his
career going yeah you got to find a
quarterback I mean he found a player now
pop with the draft pick with a lottery
that he can win some championships with
and and bellich has not found a
quarterback M Jones I'm not trying to
kill him but let's be fair he's not a
Super Bowl quarterback he has not found
a Super Bowl quarterback after Brady so
one guy is going to go down in flames
and the other guy is going to have a
tremendous a a tremendous send off so
it's it's amazing how it works tells you
you got to have the players you know if
you have the players the great coach can
do his thing if you don't have the
players I care who you are the coach is
gonna he's going to struggle belich won
one one playoff game without parady in
his career with test ver you beat the
Patriots one playoff game in an
illustrious Hall of Fame kind of career
when you think about it I want to touch
on your sport Before We Say Goodbye
Bruce bochi is one of the nicest people
I've ever met in baseball and probably
was a Hall of Famer before he got this
win with with the Rangers but the
Rangers played a different style of
baseball they weren't it wasn't
predicated on we're going to strike
everybody out or we're going to you know
hit home runs that it felt a little more
of what baseball used to be I don't know
if this is just a one-off an aberration
but did the Rangers offensive strategy
did they kind of stumble upon something
here that might be imitated around the
league maybe more so Arizona with their
base with their base stealing and
Bunning and speed okay and athleticism I
mean let's face it Texas still hit the
ball out of the ballpark I mean Seager
hit home runs Simeon hit two big home
runs you know they still they they still
hit some home runs in this series is
Seager a Hall of Famer yes he's on his
and not this second
but I mean Dan he's a two-time MVP two
different teams only Reggie can say that
yeah but Reggie had a better resume
seager's got a thousand hits but at that
position yeah seager's not a Hall of
Famer this second if he retired tomorrow
but he puts another three four years
like this he is a top 10 player in the
sport okay we brought this up would you
rather be Mike Trout or Corey Seager
Seager would you rather be Julian
Edelman or Randy Moss
Moss I know edan's got the Super Bowls
okay I'm just curious about that but he
you know you're right edan's got the
Super Bowls but Moss has the has the
greatness Seager has both see Seager and
chot have both because they're both
probably gonna be a Hall of Famer zman's
not a Hall of Famer no so here's the
point would you rather be a Hall of
Famer without the Rings or very good
with the Rings boy that's a tough call
yeah yeah we debate would you whether be
Eli or Dan
Marino both will make it Hall of Fame
but let's say Eli wasn't going to be in
the Hall of
Fame I think You' probably rather take
the Rings right probably here's
something for you you may not be aware
of when Wilt averaged 50 he averaged 25
rebounds he didn't win the
MVP who did Bill Russell named
MVP but he was named all NBA second team
so
Russell Nam Russell the MVP and he was
second Team all NBA was first team all
NBA I didn't know that I don't know if
anybody has ever been MVP and not first
team all NBA that is a great one wow
yeah you got into an interesting theme
today I'm gonna use that myself on my
show a little later on good job that's
why come on I don't make any stupid
predictions all right yeah no more for a
while for a
while great to talk to you dog really
thank you buddy Mad Dog Russo host of
Mad Dog Unleashed Serius XM and uh he
has high heat on MLB Network and you'll
see him occasionally on first tap